you just have to do what feels right and
try to just be as
respectful and cautious and
as possible for kim kardashian
introducing her kids to her boyfriend
pete davidson was a big deal getting
candid on the today show about leaning
on her loved ones to guide her luckily i
have a sister that has been through it
all and we talked about it and i
consulted with a few therapists and
friends that have been through it so i
definitely wanted to wait six months
and that was like the marker and i think
it's different for everyone and
different things work for different
people the reality star was pretty
cautious introducing her little ones
north saint chicago and some to pete
mainly because she didn't know if things
with her bow were moving in a serious
direction i text him i wasn't even
thinking like oh my god i'm going to be
in a relationship with him i was just
thinking like
heard about this bde need to get out
there but now we know they're the real
deal with the source telling e.t earlier
this month kim and pete are very
invested in each other and feel closer
than ever he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing and judging
from keith's pda field getaway in tahiti
we can see the pair is enjoying quality
time together kim even says the snl alum
passed the boyfriend test by catching
her best angles for her solo vacay picks
the best way to describe it was just
really relaxing
like
to be away from four kids for just even
a few days
is heaven but before kim and pete found
love the reality star admits she took
her time dipping her toes back in the
dating pool you'll recall kim filed for
divorce from her estranged husband kanye
west back in february 2021 i waited like
a good 10 months before i was ready to
open myself up and i think you
definitely need that time to yourself
and then once you're ready to get out
there i just i felt like i just wanted
new energy and something different and
it definitely took me by surprise based
on kanye's antics on social media and in
his music
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
yeah seems he's not exactly down with
kim dating again but kim says the two
are in communication and co-parenting
you know it's it's going good we had you
know
father's day at the house he the kids
you know spent the day with him and then
we had a big father's day dinner
and north cooked of course i wanted to
honor and respect the amazing people and
fathers men in my life that have raised
me and are raising my children the mom
of four shared a sweet tribute to yay on
father's day writing thank you for being
the best dad to our babies and loving
them the way you do
i think our kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path
[Music]
you